meow hi I'm an intelligent no no you
know you're like it's different now I'm
in New York City you tell my boards is
clearly boards because I've been
participating in many a YouTube event
while I've been out here for the last
couple days and I thought I would make a
stream-of-consciousness video created
today because a lot of stuff has
happened over the last couple days and I
have yet to process all of it here's
just a few things that have happened to
me over the last couple days well Smith
talked in a room in which I was also in
and he was great I had to interview the
CEO of Beyonce's company a guy named
Steve Hammond who is absolutely
incredible and I have you healed brain
that's melted when we were backstage
before the interview talking and getting
to know each other
referred to jay-z as Jay and he referred
to Beyonce is big he said something
about Blue Ivy so casually on the
outside I was like you know I too have
experienced that but on the inside I was
like how Katy Perry performed live a
giant room with a bunch of men in suits
it clearly fell uncomfortable dancing
also did not know what to do with our
bodies when music was being performed in
front of them so they just took their
phones and held it up and recorded the
video just so they had something to do
with their answer Ned we're gonna watch
that video can what are you doing I
broke my phone train wow that's
aggressive and concerning about the
quality of life I live watch it yeah
yeah I'm doing just fine
did you know that those in toilet paper
sitting there this whole time and then I
went to the musical Cats and it was
incredibly confusing I had absolutely no
idea what was happening the entire show
and I was so okay with that because
confusion keeps you present what all
this happened oh yeah um one part to the
video in one part because my stuffs
malicious I parted my hair kind of dumb
center and I don't feel the worst about
it that's exciting
well contest
you get it performance art from
America's Bjork
I would enough sushi for a family of six
and they give me that on the house and
it's fruit oh no one everywhere that was
very expected sweet stupid and dog on
the fun stupidest yeah and I wore men's
doctor since I was on a boat for a
second it was minutes actually exciting
to feel what the outdoors feels like
every now and then turns out it's cold
and I'm not bred for survival out there
just me flex don't the mystery bruises
on my body which is always fun to know
that the only thing I'm consistent in is
my inability to understand my own
personal spatial awareness that's
awesome that's it special set a me catch
thanks me when I landed in New York I
realize that I did not pack my computer
charger or my phone charger but I did
pack he is glasses more than three pairs
of headphones and two chargers that are
four devices I don't even have with me
lifestyle guru at your service thanks
everyone and cat is insanely talented
their voices are amazing the dancing is
out of control I have never seen a
Broadway show with the caliber of
dancing that cat had nor have I ever
seen a Broadway show with the caliber of
confusion that myself had you want to
feel like you're hallucinating
without the like emotional and physical
exhaustion of taking Colusa no genic I
was definitely a seeing it I like
insinuated all the cats like got in heat
and like we're doing some you know
passionate romantic animal things with
each other and then it cut to
intermission and there was a cat on
stage and all the kids in the audience
go take a photo with so it's a complete
unpredictable rollercoaster of emotion
like have you ever been on a roller
coaster where you're like not sure they
finished the tracks for the roller
coaster and it's completely in the dark
and you don't get to wear a seatbelt but
everyone's really cool and nice about it
okay remembers now thank you for
watching and this true
this video if you guys like these kind
of videos get this filled sums up and
don't forget to comment down below let
me know what's the live show that you've
seen recently I would love to know if
you don't forget to subscribe to future
channel i make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometimes oftentimes not but
sometimes not a completely false
statement but also not totally true and
a little Dietrich's much as I can also
do trick shots so d search boxes I can
also do a trick shots with props 15
tricks trick shot